Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Oh, not for me, oh, not for me, that fatal toy of gems and gold. Blood on its ermined band I see, and thorns are in its silken folds. Let me the shaded pathway keep, remote from wild ambition's glare. Nor lead me to that dizzy steep for clouds and storms are gathering there she died that glory of her age as never roman heroine died and britain's history has no page dearer to british woman's pride that was a poem by the American writer Eliza Leslie. She wrote it in 1833
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告播客、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。哦，不属于我，哦，不属于我，那迷人的珠宝与黄金的致命玩物。我看到它那饰有 ermine（白貂皮）的边带上有血迹，丝绒的褶皱里藏着荆棘。让我留在那阴凉的小路上，远离野心勃勃的刺眼光芒。不要把我引向那令人眩晕的陡坡，因为云雾和风暴正在那里汇集。她死去了，作为她那个时代的荣耀，正如从未有过罗马女英雄那样死去，英国历史上没有哪一页比这更贴近英国女性的骄傲。这是美国作家伊丽莎小（Eliza Leslie）写的一首诗。写于1833年
and it is about the subject of the last podcast we did and this podcast, Lady Jane Grey, Lady Jane Dudley, Queen Jane, however you want to call her, the nine days queen, the 13 days queen. The woman of a thousand names. Yeah, very difficult to pin down. And Dominic, in part one, we set up the situation. We introduced all the various characters. And we left Jane in tears in the Long Gallery at Sion House, proclaimed queen by the Duke of Northumberland,
这首诗的主题就是我们上期播客以及这期播客的主角——简·格雷女士（Lady Jane Grey）、简·达德利女士（Lady Jane Dudley）、简女王，无论你想怎么称呼她：九日女王，十三日女王。一个拥有上千个名字的女性。是的，非常难以界定。多米尼克，在第一部分中，我们铺垫了当时的局势。我们介绍了所有不同的角色。我们离开简时，她正泪洒锡安宫的长廊，被诺森伯兰公爵宣告为女王，
power behind Edwardward the sixth throne ardent protestant and he has kind of um he has signed up to edward the sixth wheeze to keep his cath his elder catholic sister mary from the throne by essentially saying that jane should become queen Jane I. Yes. So that's the state of play. So Jane has burst into tears. How long does it take her to get her composure back and to agree to become queen? Presumably, I mean, what if she had turned around
他是爱德华六世王位背后的权臣，一位狂热的新教徒，他某种程度上……他支持了爱德华六世的鬼把戏，试图阻止他年长的天主教姐姐玛丽登上王位，其核心逻辑就是让简成为女王，即简一世。是的。这就是目前的局势。所以简突然放声大哭。她花了多久才恢复镇定并同意成为女王？按理说，如果她当时转过身去
and said, no, I don't want this. Mary's the legitimate queen. Because she knew Mary quite well, didn't she? I mean, they were cousins. Of course, they are cousins she knows she knows mary and of course there's that there are two people who she might think could could um succeed instead of her so one is mary and one is elizabeth um so mary's 37 we talked about her in the last episode she's a catholic um she's been a victim all her life and the other person person is Elizabeth. She's also been a victim in a way. She's 20. She's a Protestant. She could succeed too. Why doesn't Jane... Jane clearly has doubts
说：“不，我不要这个。玛丽才是合法的女王。”因为她对玛丽很了解，不是吗？我的意思是，她们是表亲。当然，她们是表亲。她认识玛丽。当然，还有另外两个人，她可能会觉得他们可以……可以取代她。其中一个是玛丽，另一个是伊丽莎白。玛丽37岁了，我们在上一集中讨论过她，她是个天主教徒，一辈子都是受害者。而另一个人是伊丽莎白。某种程度上，她也是个受害者。她20岁，是个新教徒，她也可以继位。为什么简……简显然从一开始
from the beginning. You can tell by her incredulity and by the tears. I mean, obviously, she's mourning her cousin, Edward. But she's in shock that this sort of chalice has been handed to her. Why doesn't she because she's used i would say tom to being bossed around by men um you know everybody all these bigwigs all the big men of the realm are basically saying to her you're the queen they're kneeling to her she's in she's stunned she hasn't been prepared for it she hasn't been trained nobody has said to her you know even weeks beforehand somebody could have said to her listen listen, get ready, sort yourself out, start looking at maps and thinking about tax plans. You're going to be the queen.
就心存疑虑。从她的难以置信和眼泪就能看出来。当然，她在为表兄爱德华服丧。但这种类似圣杯的东西被交到她手里，让她感到震惊。为什么她没有……因为汤姆，她习惯了被男人呼来喝去，你知道的，所有人，王国里所有的大人物，基本上都在对她说：“你是女王。”他们向她下跪。她惊呆了。她对此毫无准备，也没有受过训练。没有人对她说，哪怕是几周前，有人对她说：“听着，听着，准备好，把事情理清楚，开始看地图，考虑税收计划。你就要成为女王了。”
Nobody has said this to her. She's 15 years old. And, you know, what does a 15-year-old do when all the most powerful people in the realm are saying you are the monarch? I mean, ultimately, by the evening, it's clear that she has agreed. Well, we've got a couple of questions here. One from Lauren Dillon. I'm curious how much of a role Jane herself played in her ascension to the throne. Was she manipulated or ambitious? And how did she feel about Mary personally? So your answer to that would be that she's manipulated into it. She's not an agent. And again, Reasonable Doctor, how much was she a pawn in the power
没有人对她说过这些。她才15岁。而且，你知道的，当王国里所有最有权势的人都说你就是君主时，一个15岁的孩子能做什么呢？总之，到了傍晚，很明显她已经同意了。这里有几个问题。一个来自劳伦·迪隆（Lauren Dillon）：“我很好奇，简本人对她登上王位起到了多大作用？她是被操纵的，还是有野心的？她个人对玛丽有何看法？”所以，你的回答应该是她是被操纵才卷入其中的。她并不是一个主动的主体。还有，来自“理智医生”（Reasonable Doctor）的问题：“在更有权势的男人的权力斗争中，她有多少程度是个棋子？她对权力登顶又负有多少共谋责任？”我的意思是，她对权力的登顶并没有共谋，但问题在于她有多大程度上是个棋子？
struggles of more powerful men? And how far was she complicit in her ascension to power? I mean, so she's not complicit in her ascension to power, but the question of how much she is a pawn. So to what extent is she a pawn? To what extent is she a puppet once she has agreed to become queen? Because the moment she agrees to that, she then has a degree of power that she did not previously have right and we see that on the next day so i mean again our sources are quite limited but we get a sense of it um and a sense of what how things might have worked out on the next day so on monday the 10th of july she is proclaimed queen in the city so this is the big moment when you know the heralds or whoever pitch up and the big crowd,
她究竟在多大程度上是个棋子？一旦她同意成为女王，她在多大程度上是一个提线木偶？因为从她同意的那一刻起，她就拥有了以前所没有的某种权力。没错，我们在第二天就看到了这一点。当然，我们的史料非常有限，但我们能感受到这一点，也能感受到事情在第二天可能会如何发展。因此，在7月10日星期一，她在伦敦被宣告为女王。所以这是一个重大时刻，传令官之类的人出现，聚集了大量人群，
and they sort of shout that the king is dead, there is the queen. And people are kind of surprised, I think. A lot of the crowds are taken aback. They're sort of expecting it would be Mary, but it's Jane. Am I right, Dominic? Am I right that normally when this is done, it's quite a brief announcement. It's basically, you know, if the king is dead, God save the king, all that kind of stuff. But when Jane's accession is announced, it's quite long. They have to explain it. And if
他们高喊国王已驾崩，女王万岁。人们有点惊讶，我想。许多人群都感到震惊。他们本来预料会是玛丽，结果却是简。我说的对吗，多米尼克？我说的对吗，通常这种宣布都是相当简短的？基本上就是，如果国王死了，上帝保佑国王，诸如此类。但当宣布简即位时，却相当长。他们必须解释原因。如果你
you're explaining, you're losing, aren't you? It's the classic thing. I think you're absolutely right. Mary has a very simple, straightforward, clear case, and Jane doesn't. With Jane, you have to always explain why she's queen, why these other people have been cut out. And I think that is obviously a problem from the very beginning. However, we'll come on to Mary in a second. Let's just stick with Jane and her story. Most people, I think, assume that the ambassadors and so on, the courtiers,
在解释，你就输了，对吗？这是一个经典规律。我想你完全说得对。玛丽的立场非常简单、直接、明了，而简则不然。对于简，你总是必须解释为什么她是女王，为什么其他人被排除在外。我认为这从一开始就是一个问题。不过，我们一会儿再谈玛丽。我们先专注于简和她的故事。大多数人，我想，都会假设大使之类的人、朝臣们，
she's got all the big men of the realm behind her. She's going to prevail. This isn't actually going to be terribly contested. This is going to work out. There's no rioting in London. People aren't sort of roaring and rampaging through the streets. But there's no great enthusiasm, is there? No, there isn't a great enthusiasm.
她身后有王国里所有的大人物。她会取胜的。这实际上不会有太大的争议。这会顺利进行。伦敦没有发生暴动。人们也没有在街上怒吼横行。但也没有表现出巨大的热情，不是吗？不，确实没有表现出极大的热情。
But don't forget, Henry VIII had married wives. There'd been never any great enthusiasm for Anne Boleyn. In fact, when Anne Boleyn had gone through the streets, when she had been crowned, she had complained to Henry VIII and said, everybody hates me and, you know, no one is cheering. So to have that, that's not unprecedented. You know, once you're crowned, once it's happened, I mean, who cares if no one's cheering?
但别忘了，亨利八世结过很多次婚。从来没有人对安妮·博林表现出过巨大的热情。事实上，当安妮·博林穿过街道、加冕时，她曾向亨利八世抱怨说：“每个人都恨我，你知道的，没有人欢呼。”所以有这种反应并不是史无前例的。你知道的，一旦你加冕了，一旦事情发生了，谁在乎有没有人欢呼呢？
You're the queen. They stage a big spectacle, as you're crowned, once it's happened, I mean, who cares if no one's cheering? You're the queen. They stage a big spectacle, as you would expect. She arrives in splendor at the Tower of London. She's splendidly dressed. All the family are there. All the bigwigs are there. Guildford is there. Okay.
你就是女王。他们会举办一场盛大的奇观，正如你所预料的那样。她以极其华丽的排场抵达伦敦塔。她盛装打扮。所有的家人都在那里。所有的大人物都在那里。吉尔福德也在那里。好吧。
So on the question of her family, there are two things, aren't there? The first is that her mother is carrying her train and this upsets people because it's the mother acting as the servant to the daughter upends propriety. And in an age where propriety is incredibly important, this is seen as very sinister. But the other thing is, is essentially she refuses to allow Guilford to become king. Yeah. I mean, this is this is a key point. So she's given all the sort of the stuff when she arrives in the royal lodgings. But one of the things she's given is the crown.
关于她的家人，有两件事，不是吗？第一件事是她的母亲帮她提着裙裾，这让人们感到不安，因为母亲充当女儿的仆人颠覆了纲常。在这个纲常极其重要的时代，这被视为非常险恶的征兆。但另一件事是，她基本上拒绝让吉尔福德成为国王。是的。我的意思是，这是一个关键点。当她到达皇家住所时，她被赋予了各种各样的东西。但其中一样东西就是王冠。
And interestingly, she refuses to put the crown on. Now, one reason for that might be that she feels very, you know, she still feels very conflicted about accepting the royal title. But another reason is that she doesn't like the idea of Guildford having a crown. And she actually explicitly says at this point, he's not going to be king. When it's all done and dusted, I'm going to make him Duke of Clarence. So in other words, he'll be Prince Philip. We were talking in the last episode about King Guildford.
有趣的是，她拒绝戴上这顶王冠。现在，原因之一可能是她感到非常……她对接受皇家头衔仍然感到非常矛盾。但另一个原因可能是她不喜欢吉尔福德拥有王冠的想法。她实际上在此时明确表示，他不会成为国王。等这一切尘埃落定后，我要封他为克拉伦斯公爵。换句话说，他将成为菲利普亲王。我们在上一集里讨论过吉尔福德国王。
It might well never have happened, even if she had. Well, the Duchess of Northumberland, Sir Guildford's mother at this point, has a massive strop. As she would. Your baggage. Yeah, precisely. And actually, she threatens Jane with, she says,
这很可能永远不会发生，即使她这么做了。好吧，诺森伯兰公爵夫人，也就是吉尔福德爵士当时的母亲，发了一通惊天动地的脾气。正如她所会做的那样。你这个行李包。是的，确切地说。事实上，她威胁简说，她说道：
my son won't sleep with you if you don't make him king uh now who's to say how things would have worked how this would have been resolved um you can't have a king called gilford king basingstoke i mean it's just it's ridiculous listeners from gilford please address your complaints to tom not to me. I think Guildford is a brilliant name for a king. You can't have a king named after a sleepy Surrey commuter town. Do you know what it sounds like? It sounds like an American name, Tom.
“如果你不让我儿子当国王，他就不跟你同床。”现在，谁能说事情会如何发展，这会如何解决呢？你不能有一个叫吉尔福德的国王，贝辛斯托克国王——我的意思是，这简直太荒谬了。来自吉尔福德的听众们，请把你们的抱怨发给汤姆，不要发给我。我认为吉尔福德是个极好的国王名字。你不能有一个以一个安静的萨里通勤小镇命名的国王。你知道它听起来像什么吗？它听起来像个美国名字，汤姆。
Doesn't it? Guildford Dudley. The fourth. Exactly. Well, Guildford is trying to act as a king, by the way. So this is day one. I am king! Jane! Jane, tell them i'm king jane is very uncomfortable with the whole business now one reason why um she may be
难道不是吗？吉尔福德·达德利。第四世。没错。好吧，顺便说一句，吉尔福德正试图表现得像个国王。所以这是第一天：“我是国王！简！简，告诉他们我是国王！”简对整件事感到非常不舒服。现在，她之所以感到
uncomfortable why there is also a sense of disquiet around is a message has arrived from mary mary has vanished you know mary is gone right and hadn't northumberland tried to lure her in beforehand by kind of shambolically and i think this is what proves to me tom or suggests to me that this northumberland and we talked about this in the previous episode so jane's father-in-law the the guy who had been basically Edward VI's right hand, the person who's thought of as masterminding the plot. The hand of the king. Yeah, the hand of the king, precisely. Yeah. This is what suggests that he really hasn't masterminded this plot from the very beginning.
不舒服，周围之所以弥漫着不安感的一个原因，是收到了一条消息：玛丽失踪了，玛丽不见了。对吧？难道诺森伯兰之前没有试图用一种笨拙的方式引诱她吗？我认为这正是向我证明了这一点，汤姆，或者向我表明了诺森伯兰——我们在前一集讨论过这个——也就是简的公公，那个基本上一直是爱德华六世右臂的人，被认为是整个阴谋策划者的人。国王之手。是的，国王之手，正是如此。是的。这表明他从一开始并没有真正策划这个阴谋。
Because if he had, it would have been sensible to get Mary under lock and key and secure her person before putting all this in train. And he hasn't done that. Now, I think one reason he hasn't done that is because he's improvising. And the second reason is that everybody completely underestimates Mary. Dominic, just before we carry on with Mary, just a question from Joe Johnson. What is Elizabeth doing during Grey's Nine Days? She doesn't seem to offer Mary any practical support in reclaiming the throne. Is she effectively waiting to see if Northumberland takes Mary out for her? Could Elizabeth have mounted a credible military challenge for the crown if that had happened? Or does she wholeheartedly
因为如果他策划了，明智的做法应该是在展开这一切之前，先把玛丽锁起来、牢牢控制住她的人身自由。而他没有这么做。现在，我认为他没有这么做的原因之一是因为他在临场发挥；第二个原因则是所有人都严重低估了玛丽。多米尼克，在我们继续谈论玛丽之前，乔·约翰逊（Joe Johnson）有一个问题：“伊丽莎白在简·格雷的‘九日’期间在做什么？她似乎没有为玛丽夺回王位提供任何实质性的支持。她是在有效地观望诺森伯兰是否会替她除掉玛丽吗？如果发生了那种情况，伊丽莎白能为王位发起一场有公信力的军事挑战吗？还是说她在此时全心全意地
support Mary's claim at this point? I think Elizabeth needs Mary. So Elizabeth is kind of absent from the scene, but she comes into London with Mary at the beginning of August in triumph. Because if Mary goes, then her claim is gone as well. Yeah, precisely. So basically, Jane succeeding is not good news for Elizabeth because Elizabeth is out. And if Jane then has children, Elizabeth is completely forgotten. So remember, it's not just Mary as a Catholic who's been got rid of by the Jane stratagem.
支持玛丽的声索？”我认为伊丽莎白需要玛丽。所以伊丽莎白在某种程度上缺席了这场场景，但她在8月初与玛丽一起以胜利者的姿态进入伦敦。因为如果玛丽倒台了，那么她的声索也就随之消失了。是的，完全如此。所以基本上，简的继位对伊丽莎白来说不是什么好消息，因为伊丽莎白出局了。如果简随后生了孩子，伊丽莎白就会被彻底遗忘。所以记住，简的策略不仅清除了作为天主教徒的玛丽，
It is Mary and Elizabeth as illegitimate. So it's in Elizabeth'sabeth's interest for jane to fail absolutely northumberland obviously thinks and the others think i mean this is so mary we talked in the previous episode about him in the eighth being at the center of the story edward the sixth but obviously ultimately becomes a story about mary and if you want to tell it as a it's often a story of a kind of female victim, but it's also the story of a female winner, of somebody who's actually been a victim and suddenly turns the table.
还将玛丽和伊丽莎白都定为私生女。因此，对伊丽莎白来说，让简失败才符合她的利益。绝对的。诺森伯兰显然认为，其他人也认为——我的意思是，所以玛丽，我们在前一集中讨论过亨利八世处于故事中心，爱德华六世，但显然最终它变成了关于玛丽的故事。如果你想把这个故事讲成一个某种女性受害者的故事，它其实也是一个女性胜利者的故事，一个曾经是受害者却突然扭转乾坤的人的故事。
So Mary, all her life, 37 years, everybody has written her off as just this pitiful drip. You know, she's been, everyone's abused her. They've taken her mother away. They've told her that her religion is rubbish. They've harangued her, her own, as we say. Her own brother, yeah. That fantastic impersonation from the previous episode, which will stay with many listeners.
所以玛丽，她的一生，37年来，所有人都把她写成一个可悲的受气包。你知道的，她一直……每个人都在虐待她。他们带走了她的母亲，他们告诉她她的宗教信仰是一堆垃圾，他们对她进行喋喋不休的长篇大论，她自己的……正如我们所说。她自己的兄弟，是的。来自上一集的精彩模仿，这会让许多听众难以忘怀。
I wanted to become a Protestant. No! Yeah. Edward VI, Edward VI, Botron and Boss are around. Yeah. And most of the ambassadors here in London, who are our best sources, so they're the ambassador to France,
“我想成为一名新教徒！”“不！”是的。爱德华六世，爱德华六世，高高在上、发号施令。是的。这里伦敦的大多数大使，他们是我们最好的消息来源——也就是驻法国大使、
ambassador to the empire, they basically say, Mary's a bit of a loser, you know, she's probably not going to prevail in this. The one chance she probably, they think, Northumberland's big worry, actually, I think, realistically, is he thinks the empire,
驻帝国大使——他们基本上都说：“玛丽有点像个失败者，你知道的，她在这件事上可能不会取胜。”他们认为她唯一的机会……其实我认为诺森伯兰最大的担忧，现实地讲，是他认为帝国——
so that's the Holy Roman Empire in Spain, Charles V, one of the two great superpowers, so the two superpowers of France and the empire, he thinks the empire might try to intervene in a succession. But you know what he's done? He's already squared it with the French, who are the counterweight. The French are quite happy with Jane becoming queen. Isn't Charles V writing to his ambassador and saying, who is this Jane person? Exactly. You know, what's the family tree? So it's good to know that everyone was a bit confused.
也就是西班牙的神圣罗马帝国，查理五世，两大超级大国之一，所以法国和帝国是两大超级大国——他认为帝国可能会试图干预王位继承。但你知道他做了什么吗？他已经跟作为平衡力量的法国人私下说妥了。法国人对简成为女王感到挺高兴的。难道查理五世没有写信给他的大使说：“这个简是谁？”完全正确。你知道的，“家族树是怎么样的？”所以很高兴知道每个人都有点糊涂。
Exactly. They're as confused as our listeners from the previous episode, actually. And indeed as us. So Mary has vanished. actually, what Mary has done is Mary has shot off into, where's she gone to? Was it Framlingham? I think it's Framlingham, isn't it? So Framlingham is in Suffolk. She's shot off into East Anglia. And she's thinking very fast. But at this stage, they don't know that.
完全正确。其实他们和上一集的听众一样糊涂。也确实和我们一样。所以玛丽失踪了。实际上，玛丽所做的是她直奔……她去哪儿了？是弗雷姆灵厄姆（Framlingham）吗？我想是弗雷姆灵厄姆，对吧？所以弗雷姆灵厄姆在萨福克郡。她直奔东安格利亚。她在飞速思考。但在现阶段，他们并不知道这一点。
They think, I think Northumberland thinks, oh, everyone knew Mary would create a great fuss, but who cares about her? She's just a loser. She'll probably, you know, she'll probably manage to whip up a few hundred peasants, some sort of mad Catholic squires or something, and we will just be able to disperse them.
他们认为，诺森伯兰认为：“哦，大家都知道玛丽会大惊小怪，但谁在乎她呢？她只是个失败者。她大概……她大概能煽动几百个农民，或者几个疯了的天主教乡绅什么的，我们就能轻而易举地把他们驱散。”
You know, it's the usual story of Mary always complaining. Moan, moan, moan. Yeah, moan, moan, moan, who cares? So what then happens in the next few days, Jane is in the tower with Guilford. And, you know, presumably, we don't know. We don't really know what they're doing, but I assume relations are not terribly – A bit frosty.
你知道的，这就是玛丽总是抱怨的寻常故事。抱怨，抱怨，抱怨。是的，抱怨，抱怨，抱怨，谁在乎呢？那么在接下来的几天里发生了什么呢？简和吉尔福德一起呆在伦敦塔里。而且，你知道的，大概……我们不知道。我们其实不知道他们在做什么，但我假设他们的关系并不是非常……有点冷淡。
A bit frosty. Because he's still very keen on being king. But anyway, they're both teenagers. You know, classic. I mean, it's just teenage behavior going on and in the town alone yeah and meanwhile northumberland uh who is you know appears to be the master of the situation he makes an absolutely fatal mistake and that is he says we need to obviously take some troops, go up and secure Mary, crush whatever little pitiful rebellion she's got going on in East Anglia.
有点冷淡。因为他仍然非常热衷于当国王。但无论如何，他们都还是青少年。你知道的，经典。我的意思是，这只是一种青少年行为，在伦敦塔里上演。与此同时，诺森伯兰——他（看起来）似乎是局势的主宰者——犯了一个绝对致命的错误。那就是他说：“我们显然需要带上一些军队，北上控制玛丽，粉碎她在东安格利亚挑起的任何可怜的叛乱。”
And he has the choice. Does he send someone to do it or does he do it himself? And we said in the previous episode, he's a military man. He's used to commanding. He says, I'll do it. I'll take them. And so I'll do it myself. And so he leaves the capital at the end
他面临一个选择。他是派别人去执行，还是自己亲自去？我们在上一集说过，他是个军人习惯了发号施令。他说：“我去。我带他们去。”所以“我自己去”。因此他在那个周末结束时的7月14日星期五离开了首都。
of that week on Friday, the 14th of July. And the probable expectation is that either he'll secure Mary or she'll just flee. She'll take ship and go off and spend her time moping around the course of Charles V. And he's leading a land expedition, isn't he? But he also dispatches some ships. A fleet. And these are armed with guns. Crucially, crucially. And this is the fear of imperial intervention.
他的合理预期是，要么他能控制住玛丽，要么她会直接逃跑。她会坐船离开，把时间花在查理五世的宫廷周围唉声叹气上。他率领的是一支陆军远征军，不是吗？但他还派出了几艘船。一支舰队。这些船上装备了火炮。至关重要，至关重要。这就是对帝国干预的恐惧。
So basically the fleet has been sent round the coast to try and block any attempt by imperial ships from the low countries to supply her with men or to land reinforcements or something like this. And he takes, crucially, Tom, he takes cavalry and he takes some guns himself, but not a huge amount of infantry because he thinks she'll probably be with some sort of mob of demented Norfolk Suffolk peasants. And if we just shoot some guns at them and show the men on horses
所以基本上这支舰队被派往海岸附近，试图阻止低地国家的帝国船只向她提供人员补给、登陆增援部队或类似的事情。而且，至关重要的是，汤姆，他带了骑兵，他自己带了一些火炮，但没有带大量的步兵，因为他认为她可能只带着一帮疯狂的诺福克、萨福克郡农民暴民。如果我们向他们开几炮，再展示一下骑马的人，
they'll run away and it'll be fine there's no there's obviously we're not gonna be fighting any massive battles so off he goes he gets to cambridge on the the 15th and at this point there are sort of reports it's clear that the country is not happy and and why isn't the country happy well because a lot of people probably never even heard of jane barely you know they don't really but everyone knows mary because mary is the great hard done by sob story of henry the eighth's realm so i mean on the on the question of legitimacy and a question we'll come back to i'm sure because it's the big question was jane really a queen was she legitimate i mean, a crucial part of a king or a queen's legitimacy basically depends
他们就会逃跑，一切都会没事的。这显然……我们不会打什么大规模的战役。于是他出发了，在15日到达了剑桥。此时有一些报告表明，很明显这个国家并不高兴。为什么这个国家不高兴呢？因为很多人可能甚至都没听说过简，几乎……你知道的，他们真的不知道。但每个人都知道玛丽，因为玛丽是亨利八世统治下那个饱受苦难、令人同情的悲惨故事的主角。所以，关于合法性问题——这是一个我们肯定会回过头来探讨的问题，因为这是核心大问题——简真的算女王吗？她合法吗？我的意思是，一个国王或女王合法性的至关重要的一部分，基本上取决于
on whether people think you're the king or the queen, doesn't it? Right. Yeah, exactly. And if they don't think you're the queen, then basically you're not. Yeah. I mean, you're absolutely right. I think you're absolutely right, Tom. As much as people argue about the legal niceties or the sort of theological niceties, the fact of the matter is, if the public don't think you're the king or queen, then you're not. I mean, it works on consent to some degree. Now, of course, constitutional experts will say, oh, no, no, no, no, no, it works because of important genealogical. But I mean, if the public are not listening listening there's nothing really you can do about it and what is absolutely clear i think is that irrespective of their religious views
人们是否认为你就是国王或女王，不是吗？对的。是的，完全正确。如果他们不认为你是女王，那么基本上你就不是。是的。我的意思是，你绝对是对的。我想你完全说得对，汤姆。不管人们如何争论法律上的微妙细节或神学上的微妙细节，事实是，如果公众不认为你是国王或女王，那么你就是不是。我的意思是，这在某种程度上依赖于共识。现在，当然，宪法专家会说：“哦，不，不，不，不，不，它之所以有效是因为重要的世系原因。”但我的意思是，如果公众不听，你就真的无能为力了。而且我认为绝对清楚的是，抛开他们的宗教观点不谈，
most people deep down thought that mary and elizabeth were legitimate they knew that henry the eighth had married their mothers i mean they're not stupid yeah but also i mean just to say despite edward's patronage of of um of the Reformation and the degree, the lengths to which he'd gone, I mean, it's still quite a minority sport, isn't it? I mean, people are kind of buying into it, but it's not something that has as yet become so bedded down that it's come to define how the English see themselves. Which, of course, in due course, it will. Yeah, I think there's a huge amount of fluidity. I mean, for older people, certainly they've seen, you know, religions come and go, basically. And Henry VIII kept changing his mind and changing the rules about prayer books and all these sort of things.
大多数人内心深处都认为玛丽和伊丽莎白是合法的。他们知道亨利八世娶了她们的母亲，我的意思是，他们不傻。是的。而且，尽管爱德华对新教的 patronage（资助）以及他所付出的努力，我的意思是，这仍然是一项相当小众的运动，不是吗？我的意思是，人们在某种程度上接受了它，但这还没有成为那种深入人心、定义了英国人自我认知的东西。当然，假以时日，它会的。是的，我认为存在着巨大的流动性。我的意思是，对于老年人来说，他们当然见过宗教的兴衰，基本上就是这样。亨利八世不断改变心意，不断改变关于祈祷书的规则以及所有这些类似的事情。
I mean, I do think that, you know, there is perhaps a faint sense in which the parallels between today and the 16th century are not entirely tendentious because they're coming from the same kind of wellsprings and rather in the same way that you know things that that are cutting edge in academic circles and so on are really cutting through to the general public but they haven't absolutely bedded down yet and there's still a lot of resistance. There's lots of people unhappy about it. And lots of people don't really understand it or really know anything about it at all. I think that's right.
我的意思是，我确实认为，今天和16世纪之间的相似之处或许并不是完全带有偏见的，因为它们来自相同的源泉，而且就像学术圈等领域的尖端事物并没有真正切入广大公众一样，但它们还没有完全根深蒂固，仍然有很大的阻力。有很多人对此感到不满。还有许多人并不真正理解它，或者对它一无所知。我认为这是对的。
Yeah, I think that's absolutely right. And I would guess you could say that the situation there is kind of, perhaps gives you a sense of what the mood is like in England. I mean, obviously, Mutatis Mutandis, of course, but there's a certain degree there. There are lots of people who probably don't really, I mean, don't care is perhaps the wrong expression because, of course, everybody's Christian, but are probably not massively au fait with the theological. It's just a babble to them, and they just want to get along with their lives.
是的，我认为这绝对正确。我想你可以说那里的情况在某种程度上，或许能让你感受到英国当时的心情。我的意思是，当然，在做出必要调整的前提下（Mutatis Mutandis），但确实有一定程度的相似。有很多人可能真的不怎么……我的意思是，“不在乎”或许是错误的表达，因为当然每个人都是基督徒，但可能并没有大大地熟悉神学。对他们来说这只是一片嘈杂声，他们只想继续过他们的日子。
I think there's also the Catholic Protestant thing has not probably for the lost people has not really hardened into two camps. So they know that Mary is loyal to the old ways, the former religious practices, but they don't see that as a legitimate or toxic or un-English rather, or any of those things. You know, there are quite a lot of people who are upset at just how far Edward's reforms have gone,
我认为还有一点，天主教与新教之争可能对大多数人来说还没有硬化为两个阵营。所以他们知道玛丽忠于旧俗、前朝的宗教仪式，但他们并不认为那是合法的、有毒的、或者不够英国本土的，或者诸如此类的事情。你知道的，有相当多的人对爱德华的改革走得那么远感到不满，
who are upset at seeing statues smashed and the rude screens pulled down and all this kind of stuff, and they want them back. They liked all that stuff, and they thought, why have these sort of, they probably think, why have all these foreign influence nutters, who are far too enthusiastic about their religion, smashed all our nice stuff that you know and i as you say a nice roost green that we had saved up for in the church and we'd all contributed to
看到雕像被砸碎、罗德屏幕（rood screens）被拆毁，他们对此感到不安，而他们希望恢复原样。他们喜欢所有这些东西，他们可能心想：为什么所有这些外国影响的疯子，对他们的宗教狂热得过头，要砸碎我们所有美好的东西呢？你知道的，就像你说的，我们好不容易在教堂里攒钱、大家一起出资买下的一个漂亮的罗德屏幕。
so yes i agree so so it's not as you say it's not absolutely set in concrete yet so mary despite the fact that she's catholic you know there's a there's her catholicism is less significant to people than the fact that she is henry viii's eldest child so while um what's his name, Northumberland is marching into East Anglia, what's Mary doing? So Mary's sending out letters. And actually, when you look at the correspondence, her letters often don't even mention religion. They just say, I'm absolutely the legitimate heir. I'm the legal heir.
所以，是的，我同意。所以——正如你所说——它还没有完全凝固成混凝土。所以玛丽，尽管她是天主教徒——你知道的，她的天主教身份在人们眼中，没有她是亨利八世长女这一事实来得重要。所以，当那个叫什么名字的诺森伯兰正向东安格利亚进军时，玛丽在做什么呢？所以玛丽在发出信件。实际上，当你查看信件往来时，她的信件甚至经常不提宗教。她们只是说：“我绝对是合法的继承人。我是法定的继承人。”
And she is very- Which is strategically the right thing to do, right? It is very strategically the right thing to do right it's absolutely strategically the right thing i mean she plays a very you know she plays politically a very canny game her it seems that basically her her campaign the people running it are catholics are the people around her and there's a sort of conservative network that it spreads along. You know, the people disseminate the letters and they carry messages and all that sort of stuff. But she's backed by lots of Protestants. And there are lots of people who have got, there are always people in 16th century who were grievances against the regime.
而且她非常……这在战略上是正确的做法，对吧？这在战略上绝对是正确的做法。我的意思是，她玩了一场非常……在政治上她玩了一场非常精明的手腕。她……看起来基本上她的竞选活动、运营这些活动的人都是天主教徒，也就是她周围的人，并且沿着某种保守派网络传播开来。你知道的，人们分发信件、传递消息等等。但她得到了许多新教徒的支持。而且有许多人拥有……在16世纪，总有人对政权抱有不满。
And particularly, this is why it's really important that she's in East Anglia. She had a lot of support in East Anglia. She had land in East Anglia. She'd taken over of support in East Anglia. She had land in East Anglia. She'd taken over the old affinity of the Dukes of Norfolk. She'd taken over a lot of that kind of network. So Framling had been owned by the Howards. Exactly, the Howard network. She'd taken that.
尤其是，这就是为什么她在东安格利亚至关重要。她在东安格利亚拥有大量支持。她在东安格利亚拥有土地。她接管了诺福克公爵家族旧有的追随网络（affinity）。她接管了很大一部分那种网络。所以弗雷姆灵厄姆曾属于霍华德家族。没错，霍华德网络。她接管了那个。
One of the most powerful networks in England. The boss of Duke of Norfolk, he's in the Tower of London. He's been disgraced. But she's taken that over in his absence. He was due to be executed, wasn't he? The day after Edward VI dies, I think. Is that right? I didn't know.
英格兰最强大的网络之一。诺福克公爵的老板，他现在在伦敦塔里。他失势了。但他趁他不在时接管了那个网络。他本该被处决的，不是吗？就在爱德华六世去世的第二天，我想。是这样吗？我不知道。
I'd missed that detail. Yeah. So that's a lucky escape for him. It is a lucky escape for him. But she's also, East Anglia also matters because there've been lots of risings against enclosures. So for people who don't know, this is the practice of big landowners
我漏掉了这个细节。是的。所以对他来说这是一次幸运的逃脱。对他的确是一次幸运的逃脱。但她之所以重要，还因为东安格利亚有许多反对圈地运动的起义。所以对于不知道的人来说，这是大土地所有者
enclosing land with fences and hedges and things to stop the common people using it. So very, very unpopular with the sort of ordinary folk. And there'd been a great uprising called Ketz Rebellion against this, and that had been put down by none other than the Duke of Northumberland. So basically in that area, everybody hates him, whether they're Catholic, Protestant, or whatever they are. So Mary is getting more and more support. And what clearly happens is that Northumberland had marched out of London on Friday the 14th, and he's got to Cambridge. He stays in Cambridge.
用栅栏、树篱等东西把土地圈起来，阻止普通百姓使用它的做法。因此，这在普通民众中非常非常不受欢迎。当时曾发生过一场名为凯特叛乱（Ketz Rebellion）的大规模起义来反对这种做法，而这场起义正是被诺森伯兰公爵本人镇压的。所以基本上在那个地区，每个人都讨厌他，无论是天主教徒、新教徒还是别的什么人。因此，玛丽获得了越来越多的支持。显而易见的情况是，诺森伯兰在7月14日星期五率军离开伦敦，他到达了剑桥。他留在剑桥。
He's hoping to get reinforcements on Tuesday the 18th. So just over a week into Jane's reign, he marches out of Cambridge and he thinks to confront Mary in her ragtag band. And the next day, Wednesday, he falls back. He unaccountably, it seems, returns to Cambridge. So it's like he's lost his nerve. What's going on? Well, what's going on is this issue of the fleet that you had talked about before. Another of his disastrous errors is sending that fleet to forestall imperial intervention. Some of the fleet have deserted with those guns that you mentioned. Now, they haven't done that because they're all raging aficionados of the Bishop of Rome. They've done that because they haven't done that because they're all you know raging aficionados of the bishop of rome they've done that because they haven't been paid and basically mary's agents say oh haven't
他希望在7月18日星期二获得增援。就在简统治大约一周后，他从剑桥出发，以为能在玛丽的乌合之众面前与她对峙。而在第二天，即星期三，他撤退了。他莫明其妙地——似乎是这样——回到了剑桥。这就像是他失去了勇气。到底发生了什么？好吧，发生的事情正是你之前谈到的舰队问题。他犯下的另一个灾难性错误就是派那支舰队去阻止帝国干预。舰队中的一些人带着你提到的那些火炮开小差了。现在，他们这么做并不是因为他们全是罗马主教的狂热拥趸。他们这么做是因为……他们这么做是因为……你知道的，罗马主教的狂热拥趸。他们这么做是因为他们没有拿到军饷。基本上玛丽的特工说：“哦？你们还没拿到军饷？哦，好吧，我们会付给你们的。是的，把你们的炮交出来，来吧，加入……”你知道的，她在那里有后勤保障。然后，诺森伯兰——这个马基雅维利式的阴谋家，你知道，他知道自己无法带着所有这些火炮和舰队击败玛丽。他在撤退。而在同一天，即7月19日星期三，这也是伦敦留守的枢密院的许多成员在诺森伯兰不在场的情况下做出决定的日子。是的。哇。
you been paid oh well we'll pay you yeah give us your guns come on join the you know she's the logistic there and uh northumberland so this machiavellian conspirator you know he he knows he can't defeat mary with all these guns and the fleet. He's falling back. And the same day, Wednesday the 19th, is the same day that a lot of the Privy Council back in London with Northumberland not there. Yeah. Whoa. They're like, hmm, this is not working out.
他们觉得：“嗯，这行不通啊。”
This hasn't gone as we'd thought. So Eric Ives in his book says, one one the key factor is this is the moment where basically they have to decide are they going to raise troops themselves to help him or are they not going to and actually when it comes push times to shove yeah not doing something's easier isn't it not doing something is easier you know they start thinking you know what i mean it was a stupid the public you know they're getting reports in from kind of gentry people that they know yeah saying you know jane who that who's jane i mean you know why are we backing mary and they start to it's like it's like this sort of strange alchemy of a of a particularly bitter tory leadership race yes you know yeah we always hated him yeah we never voted for him yeah i never like everything he did was rubbish
这没有像我们想象的那样发展。所以埃里克·艾夫斯（Eric Ives）在他的书中说，一个关键因素是，这是他们基本上必须决定他们是自己招募军队去帮他，还是不帮他的时刻。而当到了紧要关头时，是的，什么都不做更容易，不是吗？什么都不做更容易。你知道，他们开始琢磨：“你知道我的意思吗？这真是个蠢主意……”公众，你知道的，他们从他们认识的乡绅那里收到了报告，是的，上面写着：“简？那是谁？简是谁？我的意思是，为什么我们要支持玛丽？”他们开始……这就像是一种奇怪的炼金术，类似于一场特别痛苦的托利党领袖竞选。是的。你知道的，“我们一直都讨厌他。”“是的，我们从来没投过他的票。”“是的，我从来不……他做的一切都是垃圾。”
exactly they're sajid javid in this analogy is what they are so the councillors on that morning wednesday morning they say actually we've changed our minds we never really backed jane and so that afternoon yet yet again, you know, in the city of London, somebody proclaims, oh, it's actually Mary who's queen. And this time the city goes, the city is delighted. And I think that's, in a weird way, you know, this is a very long-running story because England had always been very, very favourable to Catherine of Aragon.
完全正确。在这个比喻里，他们就是萨吉德·贾维德（Sajid Javid），他们就是这种人。所以那天早上的议员们，在星期三早上，他们说：“其实我们改变主意了。我们从来没有真正支持过简。”所以在那天下午，又一次，在伦敦市里，有人宣告：“哦，其实玛丽才是女王。”而这一次，伦敦市民感到……伦敦市民欣喜若狂。我认为，从某种奇怪的角度来看——这是一个历时很长的故事，因为英格兰一直对阿拉贡的凯瑟琳非常非常有好感。
You know, people had loved Catherine of Aragon. She was really popular. And people had always felt really sorry for her. So when she was being shuttled around all the various houses that Henry VIII sent her to, there would always be crowds weeping and shouting, you know, God bless you, Mom, and all this sort of thing. And this is basically how people think of Mary as well. They don't think of her as Bloody Mary.
你知道的，人们很喜爱阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。她真的很受欢迎。人们一直对她感到非常同情。所以当她被亨利八世派去的人辗转送往各个宅邸时，总会有大批群众哭泣并高喊：“上帝保佑你，夫人，”以及所有诸如此类的事情。这基本上也是人们对玛丽的看法。他们不认为她是“血腥玛丽”。
They think of poor old Mary, and finally she's going to get her chance in the limelight. So there's bonfires and there's bells. Of course, poor old Jane. What's she doing? She's just sitting in the tower squabbling with Guildford. Yeah. And she's completely forgotten in all this.
他们认为她是“可怜的老玛丽”，而她终于要迎来自己成为焦点的一刻了。所以到处都是篝火和钟声。当然，可怜的老简。她在做什么？她只是坐在伦敦塔里跟吉尔福德争吵。是的。在这这一切中，她被彻底遗忘了。
I mean, that's the sort's the question before about her agency. She has no agency at all. She's just sitting there in the tower, and eventually people say to her, oh, you know what? You're not queen after all. Sorry. It was all a mistake. And Northumberland gets arrested in Cambridge, doesn't he?
我的意思是，这就是之前关于她的自主性（agency）的问题。她完全没有任何自主性。她只是坐在伦敦塔里，最后人们对她说：“哦，你知道吗？你毕竟不是女王。对不起。这一切都是个误会。”诺森伯兰在剑桥被捕了，对吧？
He does, yeah. Again, it's interesting. He supposedly this sinister kind of bearded Machiavel. Yeah, and he does doublet and hose. Yeah. He just completely rolls over. Oh, dear. You know, I've made a terrible mistake.
是的，确实如此。同样，这很有趣。他本被认为是那种阴险的、留着胡子的马基雅维利式人物。是的，而他穿着紧身衣和紧身裤。是的。他就那么彻底认输了。哦，天哪。你知道的，“我犯了个可怕的错误。哎呀。”我的意思是，玛丽不慌不忙。她进行了这次胜利的巡游，并在8月3日进入伦敦，
Whoops. I mean, Mary takes her time. She makes this triumphant progress, and she comes into London on the 3rd of Augustust you know with elizabeth at her side because obviously this is in elizabeth's interests yeah so the whole the nine day 13 day issue well let's let's call it nine days so nine days from when she gets told that she's queen although if you think she was queen then obviously it's 13 day span yeah on what day does she kind of is she told you're not queen in a kind of official way what's the guillotine that drops down that makes it the 13th or 9th i think it's the 19th the 19th because it's the privy council that's when the privy council proclaim mary is so the
伊丽莎白就在她身侧，因为这显然符合伊丽莎白的利益。是的。所以，这九天、十三天的问题——嗯，我们姑且称之为九天吧。所以从她被告知自己是女王开始算起九天，尽管如果你认为她那时已经是女王，那显然就是十三天。她在哪一天被告知“你不是女王”的，是以一种官方的方式？是什么断头台落下来，让她在位的天数成了第十三天或第九天？我想是19号。19号，因为那是枢密院宣告玛丽即位的时刻。所以
privy council basically say no and so she gets told you're no longer queen and she's already in the tower and of course the tower can be simultaneously a palace and a prison and it's pretty much what happens i guess to the princes in the tower that you know one minute one minute they're royal and the next minute they're in a luxury hotel the next minute you're in the basement yeah change to a radiator yeah well it's not that bad is it i mean they're not they're not treated like you know they're treated with the the dignity appropriate to their rank and of course you know mary was very fond of her, right? I mean, Mary doesn't want to execute her.
枢密院基本上说“不”，于是她被告知她不再是女王了。而她当时已经在伦敦塔里了。当然，伦敦塔既可以同时是宫殿又是监狱，这基本上就是塔中王子们遭遇的写照。你知道的，上一分钟他们还是皇室成员，下一分钟他们就在豪华酒店里，再下一分钟你就进地下室了。是的，被锁在暖气片上。好吧，其实没那么糟，不是吗？我的意思是，他们没有……他们没有被像……他们受到了与其身份相称的尊严对待。当然，你知道的，玛丽非常喜欢她，对吧？我的意思是，玛丽并不想处决她。
No, no, not at all. So she gets put up, as is often the way, she gets put up in the sort of jailer's house and she has servants and she has dinner with the jailer. And I think she hobnobs a little bit with Guildford at the beginning. I don't know whether relations have improved. No, I think it does improve. She starts to refer to him as my Guildford. Yeah. Well, of course, yes.
不，不，一点也不。所以她被安置在——通常的做法那样——她被安置在狱卒的家里，她有仆人，她跟狱卒一起吃晚餐。我想她一开始还跟吉尔福德有些社交往来。我不知道他们的关系有没有改善。不，我想确实改善了。她开始称呼他为“我的吉尔福德”。是的。嗯，当然，是的。
I love you, Jane. Always loved you, Jane. I never wanted to be king. But Mary, once she's installed, she explicitly says to a foreign visitor who records this, he says, what are you going to do? Are you going to pardon people? Are you going to try them? How are you going to handle this? And she says, as to Jane of Suffolk, whom they had tried to make queen,
“我爱你，简。我一直都爱你，简。我从来没想当国王。”但玛丽在上位后，明确对一位记录下这一幕的外国访客说，访客问她：“你打算怎么办？你要大赦天下吗？你要审判他们吗？你打算怎么处理这件事？”她说：“至于萨福克的简，他们曾试图让她成为女王，
she, i.e. Mary, could not be induced to consent that she should die. Three days before they went to fetch her from Sion House to take her to the tower, this is Jane, and make her entry into the town as usurping queen, she knew nothing of it, nor was she ever a party, nor did she ever give her consent. So Mary explicitly says, my conscience will not allow me to execute this child. Okay, so Dominic, what everyone knows about Ladyane gray is that she does end up having her head chopped off so i think we should take a break at this point and when we come back we'll look at how it is that jane does end up losing a head we'll be back after the break and carry on with this tragic story i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment
她（即玛丽）无法被说服同意处死她。在他们去锡安宫接她去伦敦塔、让她作为篡位女王进入城市的三天前，简对这一切一无所知，她既不是同谋，也从未给予过同意。”所以玛丽明确表示：“我的良心不允许我处决这个孩子。”好了，多米尼克，关于简·格雷女士，每个人都知道她最终还是被砍了头。所以我想我们应该在这个时候休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将探讨简最终是如何失去脑袋的。我们休息之后继续这个悲惨的故事。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《历史的娱乐》。
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com.
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦绯闻，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家番外节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
That's therestisentertainment.com. hello welcome back to the rest is history um the coup northumberland's coup has been defeated lady jane gray has gone from being a royal inhabitant of the tower to being a prisoner and mary is now queen andic, you were talking before the break about how Mary is pretty sympathetic to Jane's situation, doesn't want to have her executed, even though she has clearly been guilty by Mary's light of treason because she's been signing herself as Queen and all kinds of stuff like that. However, before we get to Jane, Northumberland, what happens to him? Because if Mary's quite fond of Jane, she's absolutely not fond of Northumberland.
这就是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的轨迹》，诺森伯兰的政变已经被粉碎，简·格雷勋爵夫人已经从塔楼的皇室居民沦为阶下囚，玛丽现在是女王了。安迪，你在中场休息前提到，玛丽对简的处境相当同情，不想处决她，尽管在玛丽看来，她签下女王名号等行为已经明显犯了叛国罪。然而，在我们谈到简之前，诺森伯兰怎么样了？因为如果玛丽对简相当喜爱，那她对诺森伯兰绝对是深恶痛绝。
Yes. So Northumberland is tried in Westminster Hall on the 18th of August. So, you know, less than a month after Mary's triumphant entry into London. And to add insult to injury, he's tried by all the people who had previously agreed to his plan yeah but that's a very common tudor experience that's classic tudor behavior isn't it so it's all the people who were kind of slapping you on the back yesterday and playing bowls with you and stuff and declaring you guilty to yeah tomorrow or something so this is exactly what happens he is He basically says, and he says to them, how can you be my judges? I mean, you were in on the deal.
是的。所以诺森伯兰于8月18日在威斯敏斯特大厅受审。所以，你知道，就在玛丽胜利进入伦敦不到一个月的时候。而且雪上加霜的是，审判他的人正是此前同意他的计划的那些人。是的，但这在都铎王朝是很常见的经历，这是典型的都铎王朝风格的行为，不是吗？所以这些人昨天还拍着你的背，跟你一起玩地掷球等等，而明天就会宣布你有罪或诸如此类。所以这正是发生的事情。他基本上说，他对他们说，你们怎么能做我的法官？我的意思是，你们也是这笔交易的局内人。
And they say, oh, no, no, no, that's complete fake news. Sweet summer child. And so what happens to him is quite interesting. He is meant to be executed, I think, on the 21st of August and first thing in the morning. And it's cancelled at the last minute. And he gives his confession. He takes Catholic mass. And he says, I've made a series of terrible mistakes.
他们说，哦，不，不，不，那是彻头彻尾的假新闻。天真无邪的小可爱。所以他的结局非常有趣。他本该在8月18日清晨被处决，我想是的。结果在最后关头取消了。他发表了忏悔，做了天主教弥撒。他说，我犯了一系列可怕的错误。
The Protestantism was all a dreadful, dreadful error. Hurrah for the Pope. So he does this and is he doing that to try and keep his ensure that his family don't lose their right to inherit quite possibly yes so the historians aren't sure some people think he did it because he hoped for a pardon um hence the cancellation which is very unusual of the execution and they think then he was kind of double-crossed that the mary and the authorities didn't deliver on their end of the bargain. Some people think he did this, as you say, to protect his family
新教简直是一个糟糕透顶的错误。教皇万岁。所以他这样做了，他这么做是为了确保他的家人不会失去继承权吗？很有可能，是的。所以历史学家们也不确定，有些人认为他这么做是因为他希望能得到特赦，嗯，因此才取消了原定的处决，这非常罕见，他们认为后来他被背叛了，玛丽和当局没有兑现他们那部分的承诺。有些人认为他这么做，正如你所说，是为了保护他的家人，
so that vengeance wouldn't go down the generations. As indeed it didn't, did it? No, it didn't exactly. So the Dudleys continue to be very powerful. But he is, yes, he is executed after all. It was in the next day. So in front of 10,000 people. Now, interestingly, so he has his head cut off.
这样复仇就不会延续到后代。事实确实如此，不是吗？不，确实如此。所以达德利家族依然非常强大。但他最终还是被处决了。就在第二天。在1万名观众面前。有趣的是，他的头被砍了下来。
Interestingly, Jane, who's in the tower, is absolutely outraged by his behavior in recanting. She can't get over it. And she actually spends, and this is going back to what we were talking about in the first episode about how is Jane really that clever? Is she very well read? Is she very serious she clearly takes this really seriously because she says how could he have taken the mass how could he have gone along with transubstantiation well she's absolutely a believer she spends most of her time in the town and talking about wafers and the body of blood of christ i mean this is this is like a real you know she if she were a teenager now
有趣的是，身在塔楼的简对他在临终前倒戈的行为感到无比愤怒。她对此耿耿于怀。她甚至花了大量时间——这让我们回到了我们在第一集里讨论过的话题：简真的很聪明吗？她博览群书吗？她非常严肃吗？她显然对这件事非常认真，因为她说他怎么能参加弥撒，他怎么能接受变体论？好吧，她绝对是一个坚定的信徒。她大部分时间都在塔里谈论圣饼和基督的血肉。我的意思是，这真的很——你知道，如果她现在是个十几岁的女孩，
she'd be on tiktok talking about she really would yeah about the communion and about the details of of communion or something she takes it so seriously she'd be she'd be talking about white privilege i think she might yes that would be the new that's exactly what she would talk she's very very earnest isn't she um and actually this stage, things are going to be all right for her. Probably in the long run, she'd have been pardoned, I think. And I think Mary would have probably let her out eventually. But it's actually Mary that does for Jane in a sort of roundabout way because Mary decides to marry.
她会在TikTok上谈论这些，她真的会的，是的，谈论圣餐以及圣餐的细节之类的事情。她太认真了，我想她会谈论白人特权，她可能会的，这正是她会谈论的新话题，她非常非常认真，不是吗？而且在这个阶段，她的情况本来会好转的。从长远来看，她可能会被特赦，我想是的。而且我认为玛丽最终可能会放她走。但实际上是玛丽以一种迂回的方式害了简，因为玛丽决定结婚。
She's very keen on this marriage alliance with Philip of Spain, Charles V's son and everybody in england thinks this is an awful idea and hates philip of spain hates the idea of a spanish marriage and it's partly this marriage plan to philip that that provokes a rebellion against mary uh the beginning of the following year 1554 so late january is what's called by this point jane has actually been convicted and gilford have both been convicted haven't they they've been convicted that's true but they've been convicted with the expectation that they will be pardoned be commuted yeah so exactly commuted exactly so she was tried in november and she was given the death penalty
她非常热衷于与西班牙国王查理五世的儿子菲利普联姻。而英格兰的所有人都认为这是个糟糕的主意，都讨厌西班牙的菲利普，讨厌西班牙式的联姻。正是这种与菲利普联姻的计划，引发了针对玛丽的叛乱，时间是第二年年初（1554年），也就是一月下旬。此时简实际上已经被定罪了，吉尔福德也都已经被定罪了，对吧？他们都被定罪了，这是事实，但他们的定罪是建立在他们会被特赦、被减刑的预期之上的，对吧？所以确实是减刑，完全没错。所以她在11月受审，并被判处死刑。
she showed no reaction but i think one reason she may have shown no reaction is that she may well have thought it probably won't happen. You know, she may have been told that it won't happen. She's a kind of model of Protestant sobriety and holiness in that, isn't she? She kind of wears black and reads the Psalms and all that kind of stuff. Cuts a very good dash she's she's a great poster girl for the protestant cause actually yeah you know she's she's perfect um and we'll perhaps come on later in the towards the end of this this bit of the episode um to
她没有任何反应，但我认为她可能没有反应的一个原因，是她很可能认为这大概不会发生。你知道，她可能被告知这不会发生。在这方面，她简直是新教的庄重与圣洁的化身，不是吗？她总是穿黑衣，读圣诗之类的。给人留下了深刻的印象，实际上她是新教事业的最佳海报女孩，是的，你知道，她堪称完美。我们稍后，也就是在本集快结束时，可能会来
talk about why she wasn't a bigger you know why isn't she more well known um which is an interesting question but anyway so so she's got this kind of sentence hanging over her that's probably going to be suspended. And then there is a rebellion led by the son of a poet, isn't it? Yeah, Thomas Wyatt, the poet. So Thomas Wyatt Jr., I suppose he would be called now. Thomas Wyatt the Younger. He leads the rebellion.
谈谈为什么她没有成为一个更重要的人物，为什么她不是更广为人知，这是一个有趣的问题。不过无论如何，所以她头上悬着这样一柄随时可能被取消的死刑宝剑。接着，发生了一场由一位诗人的儿子领导的叛乱，对吧？是的，诗人托马斯·怀亚特。所以现在大概可以叫他小托马斯·怀亚特。年轻的托马斯·怀亚特。他领导了这场叛乱。
Her father, I mean, disastrously and unbelievably foolishly, they all get involved. I mean, why would you do that? Well, they do that because they're true believers, I mean, disastrously and unbelievably foolishly, they all get involved. I mean, why would you do that? Well, they do that because they're true believers, I suppose. They're proper Protestants. They don't like Mary. They believe in it. And maybe they think they're going to – the rebellion is a shambles.
她的父亲——我的意思是，灾难性且难以置信的愚蠢——他们都卷了进去。我的意思是，你为什么要这么做？好吧，他们这么做是因为他们是坚定的信徒，我的意思是，灾难性且难以置信的愚蠢——他们都卷了进去。我的意思是，你为什么要这么做？好吧，他们这么做是因为他们是真正的信徒，我想。他们是虔诚的新教徒。他们不喜欢玛丽。他们信仰这个。也许他们以为他们会——这场叛乱简直是一团糟。
Mary's able to put it down. And at that point, Mary basically – Why does she get rid of Jane? Well, Dominic, before that uh so henry gray her father he has his head chopped off and you know that it was kind of preserved a bit like oliver cromwell's head no i did not i think it got fat it got found in a crypt when was it found i think in the 19th century and it got buried quite recently and where is it now some church in london oh so i just throw that
玛丽得以平息叛乱。就在那时，玛丽基本上——她为什么要除掉简？嗯，多米尼克，在此之前，呃，亨利·格雷，也就是她的父亲，他的头被砍了下来，你知道的，那颗头颅被保存了下来，有点像奥利弗·克伦威尔的头颅。不，我不知道。我记得它是在一个地窖里被发现的？是什么时候被发现的？我想是在19世纪，不久前才被重新埋葬。现在在哪里？伦敦的某座教堂。哦，所以我只是随口把它当做一个有趣的八卦说出来，我们应该去你的某条徒步路线上去看一看，汤姆。我可能会去，是的。是的，去“头颅漫步”，所以——简，玛丽基本上说她必须死。是的，完全如此，发生了什么，所以她和可怜的吉尔福德都得死。所以，吉尔福德先被砍头，对吧？是的。所以，这就是简说“我可怜的吉尔福德”的时候。是的，没错。她看着他走出去。刀斧落下。
out as a kind of interesting tidbit we should go and visit it on one of your walks tom i might do that yes yeah yes to the head walk um so jane mary basically says she's got to go yeah exactly exactly what happens um so she and poor gilford i've got to go. So, Gilford has his head chopped off first, doesn't he? He does. So, this is when Jane says, my poor Gilford. Yes, exactly. She sees him walk out. Here's the chop.
然后看着他无头的尸体被抬回来。据说她目睹了整个过程。所以，观众相当，人群相当少。那里没有很多人，不像某些大型处决那样。所以在诺森伯兰被处决时有1,0000人，我们不知道，但观看简被处决的人可能没那么多。吉尔福德先走。女官们对简说，别看，别看，看在上帝的份上。
And then sees his headless corpse being come back. She supposedly watches the whole thing. So, the audience is quite, the crowd is quite small. There's not a lot of people there, as there had been for some big sort of executions. So in Northumberland, there were 10,000 people that we don't know, but probably not that many people to watch Jane's. Guildford goes first. The ladies in waiting say to Jane, don't watch, don't look, for God's sake.
她看完了整个过程，并说：“哦，吉尔福德，吉尔福德，”就像我刚才用那种非常感人的方式说的一样。然后她走上刑场。她全身穿黑衣，正如你所说，她拿着一本祈祷书，非常镇定，她发表了这种非常经典的都铎王朝处决演讲，但这真的很——从长远来看，令人心碎，不是吗？所以她发表了这番演讲，而且她极其勇敢。
She watches the whole thing and says, oh, Guildford, Guildford, in that very moving way that I've just done. And then she goes down. she's all in black as you said she's got a prayer book she's very composed and she gives this very kind of you know the classic tudor execution speech but it's very i mean in the long run it's upsetting isn't it so she does give this speech and she's incredibly brave yeah um you know there's no hint of i mean i've just begun there's nothing none of that at all um and the executioner asks her forgiveness and she gives it and she says you know please make it swift and he says that he will um and then she gets blindfolded oh it's an awful
是的，你知道，没有丝毫的——我的意思是，我刚刚开始，完全没有那种怯懦。刑场刽子手请求她的原谅，她原谅了他，并说，你知道，请动作快点。他说他会的。然后她被蒙上眼睛。哦，这真是一个可怕的
moment this isn't it and then she can't find? And then she can't find the block. Yeah. She can't find the block. But just, I mean... And she cries out, what shall I do? Where is it? And, you know, one of the guys has to kind of help her towards it. And then she lays her head on the block. I mean, I can't imagine how the unbelievable horror of having to compose yourself to have to give this speech.
时刻，不是吗？然后她找不到？然后她找不到木桩了。是的。她找不到木桩了。但是，我的意思是……她大喊，我该怎么办？它在哪儿？而且，你知道，其中一个人不得不扶着她靠近它。然后她把头放在木桩上。我的意思是，我无法想象那种难以置信的恐怖：必须让自己镇定下来并发表这番演讲。
I mean, the formula, there is a set formula which is that you confess your sins and you basically it's expected that you say even if you don't think you are guilty you say you're guilty as people always did um she gives the speech and actually there's a couple of things that would appeal to you tom because she's still doing theological um argument in her speech so she says uh I look to be saved by no other means but by the mercy of God and the merits of the blood of his son Jesus Christ, i.e. salvation by faith alone,
我的意思是，套路，有一个固定的套路，那就是你承认自己的罪行，基本上人们期望你即使认为自己无罪，也得像人们总是做的那样承认自己有罪。她发表了演讲，实际上有几点会吸引你，汤姆，因为她仍在演讲中进行神学辩论，所以她说：呃，我期望除了通过上帝的仁慈和他的儿子耶稣基督之血的功劳之外，别无其他途径获得拯救，即仅凭信仰得救，
which is very Protestant. And then at the end she also says, good people, while I'm alive, I pray you to assist me with your prayers, i.e. don't bother praying for me after I'm dead. Not after I'm dead, yeah. Because that's a mad papist superstition. Papist tosh. So she's still going. Right at the end
这非常新教。然后在最后她还说：善良的人们，在我活着的时候，我祈求你们用你们的祈祷来协助我，也就是说，我死后就不用为我祈祷了。我死后不用，是的。因为那是疯狂的教皇迷信。教皇的无稽之谈。所以她还在继续。直到最后
she's still going and she's still got this composure but then as you say when I think the executioner blindfolds her I mean that must be, I mean being blindfolded is scary anyway and that must be the moment when the panic horror kind of you know really breaks in
她还在继续，她依然保持着这种镇定，但正如你所说，当刽子手给她蒙上眼罩时，我的意思是，那一定——被蒙上眼睛本身就很可怕，而那一定是一阵恐慌和恐惧真正爆发的时刻，你知道的。
somebody guides her to the block um and then she says lord in the hands i commend my spirit and then bang her head is cut off okay so dominic a question from archive of the past and it's the obvious question had she lived would she have been a good ruler impossible to know absolutely impossible to know but it's looking quite good i would say she's clever she's she's modest she's rude she understood you know not to give in to gilford for instance i mean that's quite but but tom the two female rulers that um england had in the 16th century mary and elizabeth were so seasoned by comparison with jane weren't they? I mean, Mary had suffered for almost 40 years and had so much time. Elizabeth had also sort of been through the ringer, had nearly been in fear of her life. Jane is so callow by comparison, no matter how clever she is.
有人引导她走到木桩前，然后她说：“主啊，我将我的灵魂交托在你的手中，”然后砰的一声，她的头被砍了下来。好的，多米尼克，这是一个来自历史档案的问题，也是一个显而易见的问题：如果她活下来了，她会是一个好统治者吗？完全无法知道，绝对无法知道。但看起来挺不错的，我想说。她很聪明，很谦虚，她很坚强，她懂得（例如）不要向吉尔福德妥协，我的意思是，这相当了不起。但是，汤姆，16世纪英格兰拥有的两位女性统治者——玛丽和伊丽莎白，与简相比是多么经验丰富啊，不是吗？我的意思是，玛丽苦苦煎熬了近40年，经历了如此漫长的时间。伊丽莎白也经历过风雨，甚至曾濒临生命危险。相比之下，无论简有多么聪明，她都太稚嫩了。
And she's got the problem of the Northumberland family, the Dudley family. I mean, that would have been a massive issue, wouldn't it, you think in the long run so related to that question from Douglas Fife I'm really interested in whether there is an alternate timeline where she could have held on to the throne was there any way it could have happened or was Mary's succession always guaranteed I think it's definitely an alternative timeline and that timeline is one in which Northumberland seizes Mary first, probably Elizabeth as well. He's more ruthless. If they're seized and they're immediately thrown into the tower and then, you know, there's no uprising or something to free them,
而且她还面临着诺森伯兰家族、达德利家族带来的麻烦。我的意思是，从长远来看，你认为这会是一个巨大的问题，对吧？所以，结合道格拉斯·法伊夫（Douglas Fife）的那个问题，我真的很想知道，是否存在一种她本可以保住王位的平行时间线？有没有任何可能实现的方式，还是说玛丽的继位从一开始就是板上钉钉的？我认为这绝对是一个平行时间线，那条时间线就是：诺森伯兰首先控制了玛丽，可能还有伊丽莎白。他更加冷酷无情。如果她们被控制并立即被投入塔中，然后，你知道的，没有发生起义或类似的事情来解放她们，
then she's queen at the end of the year and then she's queen. Right, but she does have her head chopped off. And so earlier you posed the question of why is she not kind of celebrated more as a martyr? Well, I think it's because of Elizabeth. Because she messes with the Mary Elizabeth narrative, doesn't she? Because if Jane is the great martyr, then Elizabeth's not legitimate. And if Elizabeth is legitimate, then what's Jane even doing there?
那么她在年底就是女王了，然后她就是女王了。没错，但她的头被砍掉了。所以你之前提出了一个问题：为什么她没有作为烈士受到更多赞颂？嗯，我认为这是因为伊丽莎白。因为她扰乱了玛丽-伊丽莎白的叙事，不是吗？因为如果简是伟大的烈士，那么伊丽莎白就是不合法的。而如果伊丽莎白是合法的，那简在那里算怎么回事？
And I think that's the issue. I think you can imagine a scenario in which Elizabeth had dropped dead or something, and Mary is succeeded by somebody else. And they then said, oh, poor old Jane. Oh, she really was a queen. This is one reason, I think, why she's not considered a queen. Because it's not in Elizabeth's interests at all to consider her a queen. So let's return to Sander Fearon's question, which we open with,
我认为问题就在这里。我想你可以想象这样一种场景：伊丽莎白突然驾崩或遭遇不测，玛丽由其他人继位。然后他们可能会说：“哦，可怜的老简。哦，她真的曾是女王。”我认为这是她不被视为女王的原因之一。因为承认她是女王对伊丽莎白毫无利益可言。所以让我们回到桑德·费伦（Sander Fearon）的问题，我们一开始就提出了这个问题：
should Lady Jane Grey be considered a queen? Because she isn't, is she? She's not, you know, you have all those tea towels and rulers and things and mugs showing all the kings and queens of England. And maybe there's one or two in which Queen Jane pops up, but she's not generally counted. Do you think that's reasonable, fair? In a way, it doesn't. I knew we were going to discuss this and I was trying to figure out what
简·格雷勋爵夫人应该被视为女王吗？因为她其实不是，对吧？她不是，你知道，你有所有那些印着英国所有国王和女王的茶巾、尺子和杯子。也许有一两个杯子里简女王会闪亮登场，但她通常不被列入其中。你认为这合理、公平吗？从某种程度上讲，这并不重要。我知道我们要讨论这个，我一直在试图弄清楚我
I thought. And in a way, it doesn't matter what we think. Because I mean, just as you said before, if nobody thinks you're a king, then you're not a king. So that would be my answer. The fact that she is not considered to be a queen proves she wasn't a queen. And the kind of, you know, the constitutional legalities of it are irrelevant. Because if you're not considered a queen, you're not a queen. In the same way that Matilda, you know, back in the 12th century, there was a legal case, you know, Henry I was her father. He wanted her to become queen.
到底是怎么想的。从某种程度上讲，我们的想法并不重要。因为正如你刚才所说，如果没有人认为你是国王，那你格不是国王。所以这就是我的答案。她不被认为是女王这一事实证明了她就不是女王。而且其中的宪法和法律合法性是无关紧要的。因为如果你不被认为是女王，你就是不是女王。就像玛蒂尔达（Matilda）一样，你知道的，早在12世纪，就有一场法律诉讼，亨利一世是她的父亲。他希望她成为女王。
She was constantly zipping this way and that, running around in her nightclothes, all that kind of stuff. But she's never considered to be a queen because, you know, she's not rated as a queen because people don't think she's a queen. She was constantly zipping this way and that, running around in her nightclothes, all that kind of stuff. Yeah. But she's never considered to be a queen because, you know, she's not rated as a queen because people don't think she's a queen. And same with Lady Jane, I think. If you don't have your own entry in the Lady Bird, Kings and Queens of England, then you're not. And I think the truth of the matter is, I mean, you all know this far better than me, but with Roman emperors, there were lots of pretenders and usurpers and things.
她经常东奔西走，穿着睡衣跑来跑去，诸如此类的事情。但她从未被视为女王，因为，你知道的，她没有被尊为女王，因为人们不认为她是女王。她经常东奔西走，穿着睡衣跑来跑去，诸如此类的事情。是的。但她从未被视为女王，因为，你知道的，她没有被尊为女王，因为人们不认为她是女王。简勋爵夫人也是如此，我认为。如果你的名字没有出现在《英国国王与女王》的趣味小书（Ladybird）里，那你就不算。而且我认为事实的真相是——我的意思是，你们对这方面的了解比我多得多——但对于罗马皇帝来说，有很多僭主、篡位者之类的人。
People called it a basiliscus or something in the Eastern Roman Empire. Are they all counted? I mean, sometimes they were emperor for, they ruled parts of the empire properly in a more meaningful way than Jane did. And they're still not really counted in the lists. I would say with this, she's Inverticom's queen for such a short period of time. She spends the whole of it pretty much cooped up in the Tower of would say with this she's in a vertical miss queen for such a short period of time she spends the whole of it pretty much cooped up in the tower london with poor gilford i mean i'm not going to count him as king that's for that's for sure we're certainly not i mean and
东罗马帝国里有人称之为巴西利斯库斯（Basiliscus）之类的人物。他们都被统计进去了吗？我的意思是，有时他们当了很短时间的皇帝，他们统治帝国部分地区的方式比简更有实际意义。但他们在名单上仍然没有真正被计算在内。我想说的是，她充其量只是在引号中当了这么短时间的女王。她几乎把所有时间都关在伦敦塔里
i think that um what you say about the way that both mary and elizabeth had an absolute interest in writing her out of the story i mean they, they couldn't completely, but the pathos and the drama and the nobility that she displays on the scaffold, I mean, it has it all. It's one of the great execution scenes. But if you had your top three Tudor executions in terms of their resonance with the public, I'd go for Anne Boleyn. Anne Boleyn's number one, surely. Thomas More. Yeah. I hadn't thought of Thomas More.
和可怜的吉尔福德在一起。我的意思是，我不会把他算作国王，那是肯定的，我们绝对不会。我的意思是，我认为，你所说的玛丽和伊丽莎白都绝对有动机将她从历史中抹去的做法——我的意思是，她们无法完全抹去，但她在断头台上展现出的悲情、戏剧性和高贵，我的意思是，这一切应有尽有。这是最伟大的处决场景之一。但如果你要选出在公众中反响最大的都铎王朝三大处决，我会选安妮·博林。安妮·博林绝对是第一名，毫无疑问。托马斯·莫尔。是的。我没想到托马斯·莫尔。
Probably Mary Queen of Scots. I mean, they're all, they're kind of the brand leaders. And Jane's execution is, she's not podiuming. Even Thomas Cromwell, Tom. Or what about Cranmer with his hand in the fire? Yeah. Yeah. And I think Jane suffers suffers doesn't she because the
大概还有苏格兰女王玛丽。我的意思是，这些都是标志性的领头羊。而简的处决，她甚至没有挤上领奖台。甚至托马斯·克伦威尔也是如此，汤姆。或者克兰麦把手伸进火里的那一幕呢？是的。是的。而且我认为简很吃亏，不是吗，因为
tudors have a surfeit of heroines so um people choose their favorite wife of him with the eight yeah well we're going back to the way in which everyone everyone's female yeah so um and she's eclipsed ultimately by elizabeth i suppose there's a prostitue and heroin i mean there was a brilliant painting i mean i expect both of, by the time this goes out, both of us will probably have used this painting to publicise the episode on social media by a French painter called Paul de la Roche. It's the most famous single image of Lady Jane Greene.
都铎王朝从不缺女英雄，所以人们会选择自己最喜欢的亨利八世的妻子。嗯，我们又回到了那种每个人都是女性的状态，所以——而且她最终被伊丽莎白一世所掩盖，我想作为一个新教女英雄。我的意思是，有一幅绝妙的画作——我的意思是，我预计在这个节目播出时，我们俩可能都已经在社交媒体上用这幅画来宣传这一集了——由一位名叫保罗·德拉罗什（Paul de la Roche）的法国画家创作。这是关于简·格雷勋爵夫人最著名的单一画像。
It was done in 1834. That's the one where she's groping after the block, isn't it? Yeah, and she's terrified and she's surrounded by men in black. There's this scene of this sort of saintly figure. She's wearing white, which is completely wrong. And she's terrified and she's surrounded by men in black. There's this scene of this sort of saintly figure. She's wearing white, which is completely wrong. So it's this sort of this maiden almost suffering the kind of violation of the violence of the men. But it is the most upsetting moment, isn't it, in the story? Yeah, it is.
它创作于1834年。就是那幅她摸索着寻找木桩的画，对吧？是的，她惊恐万状，周围都是穿黑衣的男人们。这描绘了一个宛如圣徒般的形象。她穿着白色的衣服，这完全是错的。她惊恐万状，周围都是穿黑衣的男人们。这描绘了一个宛如圣徒般的形象。她穿着白色的衣服，这完全是错的。所以这就有点像一个少女遭受着男人们的暴力的蹂躏。但这确实是这个故事中最让人心碎的时刻，不是吗？是的，确实如此。
It is the single most upsetting moment in the story. And that painting was clearly influenced by the execution of Marie Antoinette. So it's kind of merging the two. But it does. I think there's something about Jane's story, which is different from a lot of these. So Amber Lynn had, you know, she conspired effectively to get herself to the top. You know, Cromwell more. They were men of politics.
这是这个故事中最让人心碎的瞬间。那幅画显然受到了玛丽·安托瓦内特处决场景的影响。所以它是将两者融合在了一起。但确实如此。我认为简的故事有某种与许多其他故事不同的地方。所以安妮·博林，你知道，她有效地密谋让自己登上顶峰。你知道，克伦威尔、莫尔。他们是政治家。
They knew the rules of the game. Jane was forced into a game completely against her will, really. Her tears were more than justified. Absolutely they were. I know, Tom, are you feeling moved at the end of this doubleheader? Yeah, I am. Oddly, it's the detail that she had freckles. I think what a lot of people take from this, Tom,
他们懂得游戏规则。而简是被迫卷入一场完全违背她意愿的游戏中的。她的眼泪是完全合情合理的。绝对是这样。我知道，汤姆，在这场双集连播结束时，你感到触动了吗？是的，我有。奇怪的是，居然是她有雀斑这个细节打动了我。我想很多人从中学到的是，汤姆，
is that thing at the very beginning of the first episode where we agreed that if we were catapulted back into Tudor England I would be chosen as king but I don't think it's just because of the sun I think it's also because of my immense martial qualities I see myself as kind of Henry the 7th figure do you? devious, cold, chill
那就是第一集开头的那件事，当时我们一致认为，如果我们被投射回都铎王朝，我会当选为国王。但我认为这不仅是因为太阳，我还认为这是因为我无与伦比的尚武品质。我把自己看作是亨利七世式的人物，你呢？狡猾、冷酷、冷静、
calculating what am I? Henry the 8th yeah you just charge over a cliff that would be my expectation well probably unfair very i suspect both of us would end up on the block to be honest i think we would i think if i was anybody i think and i know this is a terrible cliche and i apologize to everybody but i think i probably would be thomas cromwell in your dreams in your dreams you are so thomas moore you can't deny that on that ludicrous i mean he's wearing a hair shirt as we speak the patron saint of politicians dominic the patron saint of politicians yeah that does not on that
工于心计。那我又是什么？亨利八世？是的，你只会一头冲下悬崖，这倒挺符合我的预期的。好吧，这可能不太公平，非常不公平。我怀疑我们俩最后都会落得个身首异处的下场，老实说。我想会的。如果非要说我是谁的话，我知道这是一个可怕的陈词滥调，我要向所有人道歉，但我认为我大概会是托马斯·克伦威尔。做你的春秋大梦去吧！做梦去吧！你简直就是托马斯·莫尔，你无法否认这一点，太荒谬了。我的意思是，他正穿着苦修衫说话呢。政客的守护圣徒，多米尼克，政客的守护圣徒！是的，这可真——
on that note of ludicrous self-promotional fantasy from dominic sandbrook we will say we'll bid you farewell, and we will be back soon. Thanks very much for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
带着多米尼克·桑德布鲁克这番荒谬的自我宣传式的幻想，我们要向大家道别了，我们很快就会回来。非常感谢大家的收听。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的轨迹》。想要收听独家番外、优先访问权、无广告音频以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。这就是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦绯闻，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告的音频、独家番外节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。